Herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 40. Ausgabe von Raumzeit. Heute hat mich der Weg nach München geführt, genauer zur TU in München, der Technischen Universität. Denn wir wollen heute hier ein Thema aus dem Bereich der Erdbeobachtung uns näher anschauen. Konkret geht es um GOCE, den Gravity Field and Steady-State Ocean Circulation Explorer, und was es mit solchen komplexen Bezeichnungen auf sich hat. Das hoffe ich mir erklärt zu bekommen von Reiner Rummel. Hallo, schönen guten Tag. Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Ja, wir befinden uns hier genauer am Institut für Astronomische und Physikalische Geodesie, also grob der Vermessung der Erde oder auch sonstiger Trabanten. Sie sind ja ehemaliger Direktor dieses Instituts, hatten hier auch einen Lehrstuhl. Jetzt geht es schon so ein bisschen in die Ruhephase, aber so richtig Ruhe scheint noch nicht zu sein.
Nee, es sagt mir ja immer Unruhephase.
Der Unruhestand. Vielleicht bevor wir auf GOCE eingehen, vielleicht noch mal kurz zu Ihnen. Also ich habe es ja schon gesagt, wir waren hier lange Zeit Direktor vom Institut, aber vorher wird sich ja da auch eine andere Ausbildung erst mal abgezeichnet haben.
Ja, ich habe in München Vermessungswesen studiert, habe dann in Darmstadt promoviert, bin dann zwei Jahre in den USA gewesen, vier Jahre dann wieder in München an der Bayerischen Akademie und dann 13 Jahre in den Niederlanden. Es war eine fantastische Zeit und in der Zeit haben wir schon erste Ideen über diese Schwerefeldmission gehabt. In Delft, an der TU Delft. 1993 wurde ich nach München berufen und seither bin ich hier.
Und heißt das, dass es auch schon immer so ähnliche Themenlagen waren, wie sich das bei GOCE abzeichnet?
Ja, das hat sie während meiner USA-Zeit herausgebildet. Da lernte ich, dass die amerikanischen Ideen zur Raumfahrt kennen. Das war ja damals in den 70er Jahren alles noch relativ neu. Und fand Interesse dann an der Gravitationsfeldbestimmung mit Satelliten. Allerdings war das damals noch furchtbar weit weg. Das war wirklich Science-Fiction. Ja, es gab ein Programm der NASA, das wurde entworfen von einem wirklich großen Visionär, einem Geophysiker, Bill Kaula, sehr bekannter Name in der Geophysik. Das sogenannte Williamstown Report hat der geschrieben. Eine Vision, wie man Satelliten und die Raumfahrt den Erdwissenschaften dienstbar machen könnte. Und diese Vision, das ist wirklich fantastisch, wurde später eins zu eins abgearbeitet und alle Elemente sind inzwischen erledigt. Und das letzte verbleibende Element war diese Mission GOCE.
Von wann ist dieses?
68.
Ja. ESA hat dann 1978, also zehn Jahre später, ein Erdwissenschaftliches Programm entworfen. Auch da war schon Gravitationsfeld eines der wichtigen Themen. Und dann hat man sich so langsam herangetastet, aber man muss ehrlicherweise sagen, dass zu der Zeit das einfach Ideen waren, aber die Technologie einfach noch nicht bereit stand. Ich selbst, das war damals in meiner niederländischen Zeit, habe zusammengearbeitet mit französischen Kollegen, und die Franzosen hatten bereits eine Technologie, die in die Richtung deutete. Und deshalb war dort auch das Interesse sehr groß. Man braucht dafür Beschleunigungsmesser, Instrumente, die die Gravitation messen. Also die empfindlich sind bezüglich kleiner Variationen in der Erdanziehung.
Bevor wir jetzt noch mal konkret auf die Sache mit der Erdschwere kommen, das Institut, also das heißt ja astronomische und physikalische Geodesie, womit beschäftigt sich das Institut insgesamt?
Es sind zwei Professuren hier. Die eine beschäftigt sich mit der wissenschaftlichen Anwendung, zum Beispiel von GPS oder Galileo, und mit der Definition eines Bezugssystems, eines Referenzsystems, des Koordinatensystems. Man muss sich vorstellen, dass die Erde ja alles andere ist als Starr. Platten bewegen sich, Erde geht rauf und runter, man hat Gezeiten. Und heute wird für diese erdwissenschaftlichen Anwendungen ein Bezugssystem gebraucht, das ungefähr ein Zentimeter genau ist. Und das auf einer beweglichen Erde zu realisieren, das ist eine der Hauptaufgaben der einen Professur. Und die andere Professur beschäftigt sich mit der physikalischen Gestalt der Erde, die im Wesentlichen das Gravitationsfeld bestimmt wird.
Das heißt, es geht hier vor allem um die Erde als Ganzes? Um die Erde als Ganzes und sie zu vermessen. Und Bezugssystem heißt, überhaupt erst mal ein System zu schaffen, in das alles andere überhaupt eingeordnet werden kann.
Wenn wir heute von Meeresspiegelvariationen sprechen, dann sind das sehr kleine Beträge und man braucht viel Geduld, um wirklich nachweisen zu können, was da genau los ist. Und dazu braucht man ein globales System, sodass Meeresspiegel in der Antarktis vergleichbar ist mit dem in der Nordsee oder im Mittelmeer.
Gibt es überhaupt so einen Idealzustand oder kann das nur eine Annäherung bleiben, wenn man sich das so vorstellt? So die Erde, fester Kern, drumherum, dann viel Magma, alles ist die ganze Zeit in Bewegung, natürlich das Wasser, aber auch die Kontinente selber, dazu die Atmosphäre. Wo fängt man denn überhaupt an, den Bleistift anzusetzen?
Im Prinzip wird das Gerüst geformt durch eine Anzahl von Observatorien, d.h. von Empfängern, Laserabstandsmessgeräte oder Very Long Baseline Interferometry, das sind große Teleskope, die diesen Rahmen definieren. Allerdings bewegen sich diese Teleskope selbst, d.h. man braucht eine Kaskade von Modellen, um all diese Dinge, die sie nannten, zu berücksichtigen und letztlich heute auf ein Millimeter- bis Zentimeterniveau zu kommen.
man bestimmt eigentlich die Erde in seiner Ausdehnung relativ zu den anderen Sternen?
Ja, das ist ein Aspekt. Das ist die Orientierung der Erde bezüglich des Fix-Sternen-Himmels, sogenannten Fix-Sternen-Himmels, der eben auch nicht fix ist. Andererseits bewegt sich die Erde selbst. der Rahmen wird durch ein Ensemble, durch eine Gruppe von Stationen, die über die ganze Erde verteilt sind, Japan, USA, hier im Bayerischen Wald, eine Station in Wetzel, die da auch sehr markant mit tut, Frankreich usw.
Ich finde das ganz interessant, die Vermessung der Welt, wann hat denn das eigentlich begonnen? Seit wann gibt es überhaupt so eine etablierte Wissenschaft, die so eine Vorstellung davon hat, wie die Dimensionen der Erde eigentlich wirklich sind?
Begonnen hat es in der Mitte des 19. Jahrhunderts, und zwar eigentlich in Berlin. Da hat ein General Bayer, der mit seinem militärischen Dienst fertig war, eine Initiative entwickelt zu einer europäischen Gradmessung. Und aus der entwickelte sich dann ein stets größeres Projekt. Und das diente der Bestimmung der Erdfiguren. Da hat man dann weitergetan mit Methoden wie Triangulation, die vielleicht allgemein bekannt sind. Aber der eigentliche große Durchbruch wurde erreicht mit dem Start von Sputnik 1 und 2. Das heißt, was war es, 1957?
Was hat denn Sputnik dazu konkret beitragen können?
Das war der Start ins Weltraumzeitalter. Das heißt, man konnte erstmals wirklich die dritte Dimension erfahrbar machen. Es entstand bereits mit den ersten beiden Satelliten, konnte man die Erdabplattung besser bestimmen, als mit 150 Jahren klassischer Vermessung davor. Es war wirklich ein Quantensprung. Und es entwickelten sich dann mehr und mehr Methoden. Und heute weiß man, dass mit GPS global die Welt umspannt ein Netz vorhanden ist, mit unglaublicher Genauigkeit, in dem man eben kleinste Bewegungen bereits nachweisen kann.
Welche Rolle spielt jetzt die Gravitation in dem Ganzen? Also wann kam es dazu?
Bei der Bestimmung der Erdfigur unterscheidet man eigentlich zwei Arten. Das eine ist die wirkliche Bestimmung der Berge und Täler, das heißt, diese Kleinformen. Man stellt sich ja Gebirge vor, man will das sehr genau bestimmen. Das ist die Detailform. Aber die Erde als Ganzes wird in ihrer Form eigentlich bestimmt durch die Erdanziehung, durch die Gravitation. Das heißt, die Erde ist keine Kugel, bessere Nährung ist schon eine abgeplattete Kugel, wie ein Ellipsoid, und wenn man noch genauer schaut, dann kommt man zu einem Begriff, der heißt Geoid, und das ist ein bisschen ein schwieriger Begriff. Übers Geoid hat eigentlich schon ein Gauss Aussagen gemacht, der hat eine schöne Definition gegeben. Es ist praktisch eine Horizontalfläche. Stellen wir uns eine Wasserfläche hier in diesem Raum vor, dann ist die Oberfläche horizontal. Und wenn wir uns jetzt diese Horizontalfläche gedanklich fortgesetzt vorsteigen übers Zimmer hinaus, über Bayern hinaus, über Deutschland hinaus, immer schön horizontal, dann entsteht eine Fläche, die die ganze Erde umspannt und an jeder Stelle horizontal ist. Die Ozeane würden sie vollkommen still sein, das heißt nicht fließen, würden Teil dieser Oberfläche ausmachen. Und diese Oberfläche nennt man Geoid und das ist eine relativ komplizierte Oberfläche, sieht zwar sehr glatt aus, aber ist eben keine Kugel und keine Ellipsoid, sondern eine relativ komplizierte durchs Gravitationsfeld der Erde determinierte oder geprägte Figur.
Das heißt, dass es mal dicker, mal dünner und so an Stellen, wo man es vielleicht erstmal gar nicht erwarten würde.
Genau.
Also die Erde ist keine Scheibe, sondern die Erde ist eine Kartoffel.
Das ist die berüchtigte Kartoffel. Ich mag den Begriff nicht so wahnsinnig gern, aber das ist das.
Macht es aber schön plastisch. Das heißt, ich meine, von wann ist diese Erkenntnis, dass der Geoid eben so unregelmäßig ist? Man hätte ja auch annehmen können, Erde, Gravitation, alles breitet sich gleichmäßig aus. Da gibt es jetzt auch keine Schwankungen im Prinzip, muss das ein ideales Rund sein?
Ja, eigentlich war das schon ein Thema zur Zeit Newtons. Da gab es wirklich wissenschaftshistorische, interessante Streit, einen interessanten Streit zwischen der französischen und der englischen Akademie der Wissenschaft, der Royal Society und der Akademie in Paris, über die Form der Erde. Und Newton hat damals schon richtigerweise gesagt, dass die Erde abgeplattet sein muss, weil sie rotiert und elastisch ist, während in Frankreich damals noch das Vermuten da war, dass die Erde eigentlich noch zu den Polen hingestreckt wäre. Und mit den berühmten Gradmessungen in Lapland und in Peru hat dann die französische Akademie der Wissenschaft auch diese Abplattung mit Messungen nachgewiesen.
Das hat sich selbst widerlegt sozusagen.
Genau. Es war ernsthafte Wissenschaft. Und dieser Gedanke wurde dann stets verfeinert und mit dem Satellitenseitalter konnte man wirklich diese Kartoffelform schon relativ gut nachweisen. Und jetzt, wenn wir über GOCE sprechen, geht es wirklich um kleinste Details. Vielleicht ist interessant zu wissen, dass die Erdanziehung, man weiß vielleicht sogar den Wert, 9,8 m pro Sekunde im Quadrat, dass diese Erdbeschleunigung eben keine Konstante ist, sondern von Ort zu Ort verschieden ist. An den Polen etwas größer als am Äquator, auf einem Berg etwas geringer als im Tal. Und was spannend ist, ist diese kleinen Variationen von g auf ungefähr sechs Stellen genauer, das heißt auf ein Millionstel genau zu bestimmen. Darin ist sehr viel Interessantes dann versteckt für die Ozeanografen und für die Geophysiker.
Was sind denn die Ursachen, dass die Gravitation so unterschiedlich ist?
Die Massenverteilung der Erde. Das heißt, die Erde ist nicht homogen, sondern wie sie bereits sagten, man hat einen Erdkern, ein Mantel, Kruste oder Lithosphäre, je nachdem, wie man das betrachtet. Man hat dichte Unterschiede, die Platten gehen in die Erde rein, an den Subduktionszonen zum Beispiel vor Südamerika, Ozeanrücken zum Beispiel bei Island, kommt wieder Magma aus dem Inneren der Erde, das heißt, man hat Temperaturunterschiede und deshalb auch Dichteunterschiede, man hat Topographie. All dieses trägt bei zu kleinen Dichteunterschieden, die messbar sind in der Erdanziehung. Das heißt, wenn ich Erdanziehung betrachte über einem Erzlager, dann ist eben die Erdanziehung dort minimal größer als über einem Hohlraum. Aber es gibt auch zeitliche Änderungen. Dicke Zeiten von Sonne und Mond ergeben ein Auf und Ab nicht nur der Ozeane, sondern auch der festen Erde. Und das lässt sich messen. Oder wenn man ganz kleine Effekte betrachtet, wenn das Grundwasser steigt oder sinkt, merkt man das in der Erdanziehung. Oder wenn ein Tiefdruckgebiet über München hinweg geht, dann merkt man das im Gravitationsfeld.
Also wenn man morgens mal schwer aus dem Bett kommt, dann kann das auch tatsächlich physikalisch wunderbar sein.
Alles, was mit Trägermasse zu tun hat, ist im Erdschwerefeld messbar.
So, was heißt denn das, ist messbar? Wie misst man denn so etwas wie Gravitation? Man kann nicht immer nur einen Ball fallen lassen und messen, wie lange es dauert.
Aber das Ball, das ist das klassische Experiment. Das ist eine Testmasse. Und das macht man heute im Labor mit sehr ausgetüftelten Fallexperimenten. Das heißt, es werden Prismen fallen gelassen und die werden mit Lasern verfolgt. Mit einem Atomo wird die Zeit gemessen. Aus Ort und Zeit lässt sich, wenn man mehreren Ebenen misst, die Erdbeschleunigung messen, und zwar im Labor auf unglaubliche neun Stellen genau. Das ist das aufwendigste Verfahren, aber natürlich auch das genaueste. Man kann aber auch schwere Unterschiede, das heißt Unterschiede in der Erdanziehung, zwischen zwei Punkten messen, mit Federwagen. Allerdings sehr empfindlichem Federwagen, auch sehr teuren Federwagen. Und auch das ist ein sehr gängiges Verfahren, das zum Beispiel auch in der Exploration, das heißt in der Lagerstättenforschung, verwendet wird.
Um was herauszufinden?
Ob im Untergrund irgendwelche, zum Beispiel Salzstöcke sind.
Die besonders schwer werden in der Umfrage?
Ja, oder leicht, je nachdem.
Das ist sozusagen so ein Blick in die Tiefe, der einfach nur sagt, wenn da jetzt das und das ist, müsstest du die und die Masse haben.
Das ist so ein erster Anlauf, bevor man beginnt, sehr teuer zu bohren.
Zumindest kann man erstmal was ausschließen wahrscheinlich. Genau.
Aber das sind die terrestrischen Verfahren. Und das ist ein sehr mühsamer Prozess. Und diese Messungen gibt es schon seit 50, 60 Jahren. Und sie geben immer noch ein extrem unvollständiges Bild.
Aber zumindest konnte man das an verschiedenen Orten der Erde machen, die Ergebnisse vergleichen und auch daraus schon ablesen. Es unterscheidet sich. So, GOCE ist ja jetzt ein neues System, was das Ganze eben vom Weltall aus macht. Wird da auch ein Ball fallen gelassen? Wie kam es denn jetzt überhaupt erst mal dazu, dass man das vom Weltall aus machen wollte?
Also im Prinzip lässt man einen Ball fallen, ich komme auf das später noch zurück. Jeder Satellit selbst ist nichts anderes als ein Ball, der um die Erde fällt. Das muss man sich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Newton hat in einem wunderschönen Bild in seiner Prinzipie das dargestellt. Das heißt, wenn ich einen Ball fallen lasse oder den berüchtigten Apfel vom Baum fallen lasse, dann folgt der Fall dem gleichen Gravitation wie ein Wurfgeschoss, der sich von einem Berg wegschieße oder eben wie die Bewegung eines Satelliten um die Erde. Das heißt, es ist alles nichts anderes als ein freier Fall. Wenn ich also in der Lage bin, diese Bewegung des Satelliten ständig zu messen, zum Beispiel mit GPS aus noch höherer Höhe, dann ist das auch ein Fallexperiment. Und aus diesen Messungen kann ich das Gravitationsfeld der Erde rekonstruieren. Das ist das klassische Verfahren, das mit Sputnik I begann. Und damit konnte man in wenigen Jahrzehnten bereits ein relativ gutes Bild der Variationen der Erdanziehung und des Geoids erreichen. Bei GOCE geht es praktisch um die nächste Generation. Ab dem Jahr 2000 hat man neue Verfahren ausgetüftelt, um das Gravitationsfeld vom Weltraum aus noch viel genauer zu messen. Das Problem jeder Satellitenvermessung des Gravitationsfelds ist einfach, dass die Erdanziehung sehr schnell abnimmt mit der Höhe. Das heißt, da oben in Satellitenhöhe bekommt man immer nur ein stark gedämpftes Bild des Gravitationsfelds. Also sucht man nach Wegen, wie man diesen Dämpfungsfaktor überwindet, wie man das wieder verstärken kann. Da ist in der Physik immer das Prinzip, dass man von absoluten Messungen des freien Falls dann übergeht zu differenziellen Messungen zwischen mehreren Satelliten oder mehreren Testmassen. Und GOCE hat sechs Testmassen in seinem Satellitenkörper. Aber es gibt auch parallel eine andere Mission, die heißt GRACE, eine amerikanisch-deutsche Mission. Die besteht aus zwei Satelliten, die sich gegenseitig messen. Das heißt, auch da wird die Relativbewegung zwischen zwei um die Erde fallenden Massen gemessen. Bei GOCE sind es sechs Massen.
Das war ja im Prinzip die Gravitation, die die einzige wirkliche direkt auf diese Massen einwirkende Kraft ist an der Stelle. Das ist richtig.
Wenn man es genauer betrachtet, hat man dann schon noch einen Restwiderstand der Atmosphäre oder den Druck der Sonnenstrahlung oder derartige kleine Effekte. Das sind sehr kleine Effekte. Und da muss man auch was machen dagegen. Also bei diesem GRACE-Experiment misst man mit Beschleunigungsmessern im Satelliten, die nicht gestört werden durch diese Störkräfte, misst man diesen Effekt und ja, reduziert ihn oder zieht ihn ab sozusagen.
Das heißt, man muss sich im Prinzip jeden Satelliten vorstellen wie so ein Ball, der von der Erde einfach mal mit extrem starker Beschleunigung geworfen wird und dann eigentlich immer weiter fällt, aber da er gerade die Geschwindigkeit gehabt hat, dass er überhaupt erst mal so aus der Erddachspanphäre herausgetreten ist und mit relativ wenig Widerstand weiterfällt, fällt er eigentlich immer an der Erde immer wieder vorbei und wird von Zeit zu Zeit immer mal wieder beschleunigt, damit dieser Fall auch nicht endet.
Der wird ständig beschleunigt. Also es gibt zwei wunderschöne Satelliten, die heißen Laetius. Das sind sehr kompakte Kugeln, eigentlich genau das, was Sie sagten. Eine Kugel, die um die Erde fällt und man muss sich das vorstellen, dass die ständig beschleunigt und wenn ich das sagen darf, entschleunigt werden auf ihrem Weg um die Erde. Wenn sie übers Himalaya fliegen, werden sie eben stärker beschleunigt. Und dann, wenn wieder keine Massen, weniger Massen da sind, werden die wieder langsam. Das entsteht praktisch auf der beinahe elliptischen Bahn eines Satelliten so eine Art Gravitationsmuster. Und wenn man in der Lage ist, dieses Gravitationsmuster irgendwie zu messen, dann kann man daraus das Gravitationsfeld der Erde rekonstruieren.
Das ist also jetzt die Zielsetzung von GOCE, alles genau zu vermessen. Wie kam denn dieses Projekt überhaupt zustande?
Ja, ich sagte schon, wir hatten Kontakt mit einigen französischen Kollegen und es entstand dann eine größere Gruppe in Europa, die zusammenarbeitete, an ersten Vorschlägen zu einer derartigen Mission, die ist dann unter dem Namen Aristoteles verfolgt und untersucht worden, mit Hilfe der ESA. Es gab damals aber kein Programm, in das diese Mission hineingepasst hatte, aber diese Vorstudien waren unglaublich wichtig, um die Ideen überhaupt mal zu konkretisieren und mal nachzuschauen, ob die Technologie irgendwie geeignet da wäre. Und in den 90er Jahren entstand dann bei der ESA ein neues erdwissenschaftliches Programm, das sogenannte Living Planet Program. Das wurde vom damaligen Direktor Erdbeobachtung vorangetrieben. Und in dieses Programm haben wir dann Studien gemacht, zu diesem Programm. Also einen Vorschlag ausgearbeitet. Es waren dann anfangs in einer Vorentscheidung so 20 Missionsvorschläge, die wurden runtergebrochen auf neun in einer ersten Entscheidungsrunde und dann blieben noch vier über. Und 1999 wurde dann GOCE unter diesen Vieren als Erste ausgewählt, in diesem neuen Erdwissenschaftlichen Programm.
Aber die anderen Missionen waren jetzt keine ähnlichen Sachen. Das waren ganz andere Projekte.
Nee, das sind Atmosphären, Chemie, Atmosphärenphysik, Salzgehalt der Ozeane, CO2. All diese verschiedenen Ansätze sind da in Konkurrenz. Es geht darum, sind diese Ideen bereits reif? Und wie wichtig sind sie für die Erdwissenschaften? Also ein Konkurrenzkampf, ein Wettstreit, in dem dann die geeignetste Mission ausgewählt wird.
Also in den 90er-Jahren war ja so das Aufblühen der Umweltproblematik, auch im wissenschaftlichen Bereich, wo einfach in zunehmendem Maße klar wurde, da muss jetzt mal beobachtet werden. Ich jetzt höre, Erdschwere im Vergleich zu Beobachtungen von Atmosphären etc. könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass da der Konkurrenzkampf doch sehr stark war. Was hat dann dazu geführt, dass ausgerechnet diese Erdschwere-Vermessung so eine hohe Priorität hatte?
Ja, das erste ist der Anspruch dieses Living Planet Program ist wirklich ein tieferes Verständnis des Erdsystems in seiner ganzen Komplexität zu erreichen. Und warum Gravitationsfeld? Ich glaube einfach, dass Gravitation ein ganz entscheidender Faktor ist. Zum Beispiel Ozeanströme und wie viel Masse und Hitze wird in den Ozeanen transportiert. Das ist für die Klimafrage eine ganz entscheidende Sache. Und da ist eine Gravitationsfeldmission einfach sehr wichtig.
Jetzt sind wir im Prinzip schon wieder am Anfang, wo wir gesagt haben, es geht darum, ein Bezugssystem zu schaffen. Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, hat sich so die Erkenntnis breitgemacht, okay, wir können jetzt messen, was wir wollen. Aber solange wir nicht ein wirklich extrem solides und gut entwickeltes, komplexes Bezugssystem geschaffen haben, können wir die anderen Ergebnisse unter Umständen gar nicht richtig einordnen. Wir schaffen zwar neue Informationen, aber wir können sie nicht in Bezug setzen.
Das ist vollkommen richtig, was Sie sagen. Und da geht es einerseits um dieses Koordinatensystem, das wir uns vorstellen können, also drei Finger, die einfach ein Dreiein bilden, aber in einem sehr komplexen System. Und bei GOCE geht es um eine Referenzfläche. Das heißt, um dieses Geoid, das den Bezug für alle Höhen darstellt. Und bei den Ozeanen sind das die Höhen der Strömungen. Das heißt, es sind sehr geringe Höhen. Und die sehr genau festzustellen, das ist wirklich eine große Herausforderung. Ich sage das immer salopp, das sind nichts anderes als Berge oder Täler der Ozeane. Und diese Erhebungen sind nur maximal zwei Meter. Das heißt, der Golfstrom erhebt sich über dem Geoid maximal um zwei Meter. Oder der Japanstrom, der Kurochio, erhebt sich auch eineinhalb Meter über dem Geoid. Und diese kleine Erhebung gilt es auszumessen in ihrer Gestalt. Und daraus lässt sich auch wieder dann das Strömungsverhalten der Ozeane ableiten.
Zwei Meter klingt erstmal wenig, aber wenn man das auf hunderte und tausende Quadratkilometer hochrechnet, sind das ja auch riesige Wassermassen.
Das ist richtig. Da bildet sich das Strömungsverhalten der Ozeane an der Oberfläche ab. Das ist die Signatur.
Ist dann das Erdschwerefeld in gewisser Hinsicht auch mitverantwortlich für die Meeresströmung? Oder wird sie nur beeinflusst davon?
Nee, hätte man nur das Gravitationsfeld, so wäre der Ozean sehr langweilig. Ohne Wellen, ohne alles. Einfach furchtbar glatt. Winde regen dann den Ozean an zur Bewegung und so entstehen. Und dichte Unterschiede, Unterschiede in Salzgehalt und Temperatur, lassen dann den Ozean strömen. Und weil sich die Erde dreht, wird dieser mal angetriebene Ozean in Bewegung gehalten. Das ist die berühmte Coriolisbeschleunigung, die eigentlich so die Druckvariationen im Gleichgewicht hält. Der Golfstrom bleibt einfach dort, wo er ist. Er fließt nicht weg, bis er horizontal ist, sondern er hält sich selbst aufrecht. Und entlang dieser Erhebung fließt der Golfstrom entlang der Ostküste der USA Richtung Europa und transportiert warmes Wasser und ist verantwortlich dafür, dass wir ein moderates Klima haben.
Aber wenn das Wasser aus dem Abfluss rausläuft, was bestimmt, wie rum es sich dreht?
Das ist einfach die Erdrotation. Also eher nördlich im Halbrund bewegen sich alle Ozeanzirkulationssysteme, die Erhebungen sind, im Uhrzeigersinn und südlich im Gegenuhrzeigersinn. Und negative, also Täler gegenüber dem Geoid, die bewegen sich andersrum.
Das heißt, man kann jetzt nicht einfach, wenn das Beamen dann mal erfunden ist und man taucht irgendwo auf diesem Planeten auf und man möchte gerne wissen, ob man auf der einen oder anderen Seite ist, reicht jetzt Wasserbeobachtung allein nicht aus, weil man ja nicht weiß, ob man im Tal oder im Berg ist? Okay, dann doch lieber zum Mond gucken, ist wahrscheinlich einfacher. Okay, das heißt, GOCE wurde 1999 in Angriff genommen. Das heißt, da gab es dann den formalen Beschluss des ESA-Rates, dieses Projekt auch konkret anzustreben. Was bedeutet das konkret und was war die Rolle der TU München an der Stelle?
Also erst einmal bedeutet das, dass ein sehr komplexer Satellit zu bauen war. Das geht in mehreren Phasen und das wird im Auftrag der ESA von Industriefirmen gemacht. Das waren glaube ich 40 Industriefirmen beteiligt am Bau dieses Satelliten. Hauptauftragnehmer war Alenia, italienische Firma. Auch Astrium in Friedrichshafen war sehr prominent beteiligt. Und das französische Labor Honora in Paris und Alcatel.
Ich habe das noch nie so richtig hinterfragt über den Gespräch. Ist das relativ viel oder ist das normal?
Ich glaube, das ist ziemlich normal. Allerdings ist GOCE ein relativ komplexer Satellit. Man versucht erstens schon mal natürlich alle ESA-Mitgliedsländer an diesen Entwicklungen zu beteiligen, aber man versucht auch, als optimale Know-how in Europa für den Bau zu gewinnen. Unsere Rolle, wir waren sehr intensiv beteiligt an dem Vorschlag selbst, der dann genehmigt wurde. Und 2005 wurde ein Vertrag unterzeichnet. Wir koordinieren die sogenannte High-Level Processing Facility, HPF. Das heißt, zusammen mit neun anderen Instituten in Europa, verteilt über sieben Länder, sind wir verantwortlich für die wissenschaftliche Prozessierung der GOCE-Daten. Und Koordination hier in München.
Also es heißt nicht, dass hier alle Auswertungen gemacht werden, sondern dass hier koordiniert wird, wer diese Auswertungen macht.
Das ist also ein Konsortium, eine Gruppe, auch wieder mit verteiltem Know-how. Das sind holländische Kollegen und Schweizer Kollegen, machen die Bahnbestimmung, österreichische Kollegen, Franzosen, dann das Geoforschungszentrum in Potsdam, arbeiten an der Schwerefeldauswertung. Dänemark, Italien ist beteiligt. Eine sehr interessante Gruppe, von meist jungen Leuten. Ich bin dann eine Ausnahme, ich würde mal so sagen, so 30 bis 50 Leute, die da ständig dran arbeiten. Man muss sich ja vorstellen, dass das ein vollkommen neuer Beobachtungstyp war. Das heißt, es galt auch, einiges zu lernen übers Verhalten der Instrumente und übers Verhalten des ganzen Satellitensystems.
Also vollkommen neuer Beobachtungstyp, dass man das vom All aus macht, was es so vorher noch nie gab.
Ja, es gibt es eigentlich auf der Erde. Es wurden ähnliche Instrumente bisher nur in U-Boden erprobt. Und auch auf einem anderen Prinzip. Also es ist wirklich neu.
Was für Instrumente braucht man denn jetzt, um das zu vermessen? Man hat ja vorhin gesagt, 2000 hat sich eh nochmal alles geändert. Wenn man jetzt 1999 wurde das Projekt gestartet. Das heißt, gleich nachdem man wusste, man macht es jetzt, hat sich dann die technische, wissenschaftliche Basis gleich wieder grundlegend geändert oder war das so ein bisschen das Ergebnis der Zeit, was sich schon abzeichnet?
Ne, mit in 2000 entstand eine neue Generation von Satellitenmissionen. Also da entstand in Deutschland eine Mission CHEMP, die das Gravitationsfeld eigentlich noch auf traditionelle Art vermessen hat. Allerdings erstmals mit einem Beschleunigungsmesser im Satelliten. 2002 wurde GRACE gestartet und eben 2009 dann GOCE. Das sind drei Missionen, die das auf einem ganz anderen Niveau machen, als vorher möglich war. Das Kerninstrument von GOCE ist ein Gravitations-Gradiometer. Das ist das entscheidende Instrument und das ist das erste Instrument dieser Art im Weltraum.
Und was macht das? Es ist klar, was das macht, es misst die Erdschwere, aber inwiefern unterscheidet sich das jetzt von den anderen Satelliten? Wenn CHEM und GRACE quasi die Vermessung zum Auftrag haben, was unterscheidet die drei Systeme?
Das ist eigentlich, das Stichwort ist dabei, Messung von Schwere im Zustand der Schwerelosigkeit. Vielleicht darf ich ein bisschen ausholen. Wenn man eine Testmasse in einem Satelliten loslässt, so würde man erwarten, dass die schwebt. Relativ im Satelliten vielleicht sogar still steht. Deshalb spricht man auch von Schwerelosigkeit oder im Englischen Zero-G. Diese Schwerelosigkeit gibt es aber nur genau in einem Punkt im Satelliten, nämlich in dessen Massenzentrum. Von außen her betrachtet, von der Erde aus betrachtet, kann man sagen mit Newton, dass diese Testmasse und das Satellit beide vom Gravitationsfeld der Erde angezogen werden. Sie finden sich beide im freien Fall um die Erde, aber ohne Relativbewegung. Wenn man die Testmasse aus diesem Schwerpunkt rausholt, dann fühlt sich das Gravitationsfeld der Erde bereits ein klein wenig anders als das Satellit. Und sie beginnt mit einer Relativbewegung, weil der Freifall nicht mehr synchron ist. Und diese Relativbewegung, die will man messen. Jetzt kann man natürlich nicht Testmassen da frei schweben lassen im Satelliten, sondern die werden in einem Gehäuse eingeschlossen und schwebend gehalten. Das heißt, GOCE hat sechs Testmassen, das sind Quadern, 4 x 4 x 1 cm, 320 Gramm, das heißt ganz schwere Dinge, sechs von denen. Und jeder dieser Testquader wird elektrostatisch am Schweben gehalten, ohne jemals die Wände dieser Kammer zu berühren. Und das Signal, das notwendig ist, um den Schweben zu halten, ist genau proportional zu diesem Gravitationssignal, das wir wollen. Und man kann sich vorstellen, dass ein Beschleunigungsmesser, der etwas an der Unterseite des Satelliten näher an der Erde dran ist, dass der ein etwas höheres Gravitationssignal misst als eine Testmasse, die oben im Satelliten ist, oder eine an der Vorderseite misst das Gravitationsfeld ein kleines wenig in einer anderen Richtung, als wie das an der Hinterseite. Das heißt, aus diesen Ortsunterschieden entstehen kleine relative Gravitationsunterschiede.
Sind dann diese Quader im Prinzip auch so eine Art Beschleunigungssensoren?
Das sind Beschleunigungssensoren. Das ist ein Beschleunigungssensor. Und das sind eigentlich die Herzstücke der ganzen Mission. Man muss sich vorstellen, dass so ein Meter vom Zentrum des Satelliten die Beschleunigung, die durch die Erde hervorgerufen wird, ein Millionstel von der auf der Erde ist. Das ist eine sehr kleine Beschleunigung. Und diese Beschleunigung will man mit GOCE wieder ungefähr auf ein Millionstel genau messen. Das heißt, es geht um wirklich sehr, sehr empfindliche Beschleunigungen.
Ein Millionstel eines Millionstels?
Zehn nach minus zwölf.
Da weiß man ja schon gar nicht mehr, wie das passende Zahlwort heißt.
Ja, genau. Sehr klein. Also ein Beschleunigungsmesser, das ist ein sehr delikates Instrument. Vielleicht darf ich das noch ein bisschen erklären. Der Spalt zwischen diesen elektrostatischen Vorrichtungen und der Testmasse, der ist nur ein paar Mikrometer. Das war also furchtbar schwierig, diese Testmasse jeweils in diese Kammer einzuführen. Die Firma Ohnerei in dem Labor hatte nur einen älteren Herrn, der, wenn er einen ruhigen Tag hatte, so eine ruhige Hand hatte, um diese Testmasse einzuführen.
Da hat sie von Hand reingeschoben.
Von Hand reingeschoben.
Warum macht man das von Hand?
Weil das einfach am sachtesten geht. Und das Problem ist, dass man eine Verbindung zwischen diesem Quartier und dem Gehäuse braucht, mit einem Golddraht. Auch das ist eine extrem difficile Sache gewesen, diese Goldrähte zu befestigen. Die sind oftmals gebrochen. Und ein Teil der Missionsverzögerung hatte seine Ursache einfach im Bau dieser Beschleunigungsmesser. Auch der Test dieser Beschleunigungsmesser war ein Problem, weil man sie ja testet unter dem Einfluss der Erdschwere. Das heißt, man musste sie in einer Richtung viel robuster bauen, als für den Weltraum nötig wäre. Das alles waren so Herausforderungen, die diese französischen Kollegen zu meistern hatten. Aber letztlich ist es gelungen. Und wir hatten wirklich große Angst, dass während des Starts des Satelliten, bei dem enorme Vibrationen entstehen, einer dieser Beschleunigungsmesser kaputtgehen könnte.
Ja, das wollte ich gerade fragen. Ich meine, wenn da wirklich jetzt nur so, also in dem Moment, wo das Ding da eingeführt ist, dann schwebt es sozusagen in dieser Box einfach gehalten durch den Magnetismus. Und trotzdem gibt es aber noch eine direkte Verbindung, dieser kleine Golddraht. Wozu ist der erforderlich?
Um die Spannung aufrechtzuerhalten. Das wird elektrostatisch gemacht.
Also das ist sozusagen, um ihn zu laden, sodass er gehalten wird.
Und wirkt theoretisch leider wie eine kleine Feder, aber die Störung dieser Feder ist praktisch vernachlässigbar.
Und die eigentliche Messung macht man dann, in dem Moment, wo sich das Ding bewegt, ändert sich das Magnetfeld?
Wird sofort rückgekoppelt. Es ist kein Magnetfeld, es ist ein elektrostatisches Feld. Diese Testmasse wird praktisch im ruhigen Zustand, in einem instabilen Ruhi-Zustand gehalten.
Puh, wie macht man denn das, dass es den Staat überlebt? Das sind ja nicht unerhebliche Vibrationen.
Die erste Reaktion, die ich hätte, wäre, dass man die Testmasse beim Start festklemmt und die Klemmen dann im Weltraum löst. Auch über das wurde nachgedacht. Aber wenn man festklemmt, entsteht bei den Erschütterungen des Starts eine Reibung und man schürft sozusagen Material ab. Das wollte man vermeiden. Das heißt, man hat diese Testmassen wirklich frei fibrieren lassen. Und alle sechs haben das überstanden.
Woraus besteht diese Masse selbst?
Aus Latein-Rhodium-Legierung. Sehr wertvolles Ding.
Teuer, teuer.
Und relativ schwer eben. 320 Gramm. Das ist also nicht vernahrende sichtbar. Das ist eine ganz schöne Masse.
Aber auch für so einen kleinen Körper. Was war das? 4 x 4 x 1? Davon gibt es sechs Stück.
Ja, die sind jetzt praktisch entlang von drei Achsen orthogonal zueinander angeordnet. Das heißt, jede Achse hat eine Länge von einem halben Meter. Der Mittelpunkt ist das Massenzentrum des Satelliten, sodass ein dreidimensionales Instrument entsteht. Das heißt, eine Achse ist in Flugrichtung ausgerichtet, eine Radial zu Erde und die dritte orthogonal zu den beiden anderen. Und gemessen wird jeweils die Beschleunigungsdifferenz von zwei dieser Beschleunigungsmessern, die entlang einer Achse angeordnet sind.
Aber dann komme ich ja irgendwie nur... Also einer ist in der Mitte dann?
Nein, keiner ist in der Mitte. Drei Achsen, jeweils zwei Beschleunigungsmessungen. So eine Nebensächlichkeit, die sehr wichtig ist, man will natürlich nicht die Veränderungen des Gravitationsfelds des Satelliten selbst messen. Die Massen des Satelliten sind sehr viel näher dran. Das heißt, der Satelliten musste auch außerordentlich stark gebaut werden. Die Sonnenpaneele sind fest montiert. Man hat Carbon-Sandwich-Materialien verwendet. Und man muss das ganze Instrument enorm genau temperaturstabil halten.
Das heißt, dadurch, dass er so fest ist, gibt es dann weniger Schwankungen? Also jetzt im Sinne von Flexing?
Wenn sich der Satellit bewegen würde, zum Beispiel biegen würde, dann würde sich das im gemessenen Gravitationssignal auswirken.
Wie kann man das vorher planen? Woran merkt man, dass der fest genug ist?
Die Entwicklung von dem Ganzen war interessant, da waren wir auch beteiligt. Und zwar wurde für die ganze Mission ein sehr detaillierter Simulator entwickelt. Wir sagen End-to-End-Simulation. Von Anfang bis Ende wurden alle Elemente der Sensoren durchprogrammiert in Software, sodass man all diese Effekte in einer Pyramide nachweisen konnte, fortpflanzen konnte und sozusagen ein Fehlerbudget entwickeln konnte. Das war faszinierend und ich glaube, dass die ESA auch zu dem Schluss gekommen ist, dass für zukünftige Missionen ein derartiger End-zu-End-Simulator eine sehr gute Idee sein wird.
Also keine gängige Geschichte?
Nein, das war sehr aufwendig. Das wurde bei Alenia in Turin gemacht. Wir haben also nur entsprechende Software zugeliefert, wo unser Know-how war. Man konnte die ganze Mission simulieren. Allerdings war das so rechenaufwendig, dass diese Simulationen länger gedauert haben als wie jetzt die Messungen und die Verarbeitung dieser Messungen.
Das heißt, wie lange lief das?
Wir haben noch tagelang irgendwelche Effekte durchlaufen lassen, einfach um zu sehen, wie sich das oder das, die und die Kleinigkeit auswirkt.
Das heißt, man hat gesehen, wenn man jetzt dieses Material nimmt, dann schwingt es zu sehr, diese Schwingung wurde komplett in Software nachgeführt und man konnte dann gleich sehen, das hätte jetzt tatsächlich eine Auswirkung auf die Messungen, die man eben vermeiden möchte, dann nimmt man anderes Material.
Temperatur, Konstanz, aber auch noch viele andere Dinge. Das Gradiometer ist Kernstück eines ganzen Sensorsystems. Da ist zum Beispiel der GPS-Empfänger, mit dem Bahnbestimmung betrieben wird. Auf ein, zwei Zentimeter genau lässt sich die Bahn verfolgen. Und auch daraus lässt sich, wie wir es bereits diskutiert haben, das Gravitationsfeld rekonstruieren. Allerdings nicht so genau, um mehr die Globalform. Aber das ist wichtig. Dann sind Sternsensoren. Sie messen die Orientierung des Satelliten relativ zum Fix-Sternhimmel. Und das ist notwendig einerseits, um die Orientierung des Gradiometers zu kennen, andererseits aber auch, um die Drehbewegung zu bestimmen. Die Beschleunigungsmesser des Gradiometer messen nicht nur das Gravitationssignal, sondern auch die Drehbewegung, d.h. Zentrifugalbeschleunigung und Rotationsbeschleunigungen. Und die werden rekonstruiert aus den Sternsensor-Messungen. Dann, was eine Besonderheit dieses Satelliten ist, er fliegt auf einer Höhe von nur 255 Kilometer über der Erde. 255 Kilometer ist unglaublich erdnah. Ein GPS-Satellit ist z.B. auf einer Höhe von 20.000 Kilometern. Ein typischer Fernerkundungssatellit auf 1.000 Kilometer Höhe, also 255, ist sehr erdnah. Das will man einfach, um die Empfindlichkeit gegenüber dem Gravitationsfeld zu steigern. Aber in dieser niedrigen Höhe muss man einfach gegensteuern. Das heißt, die Erdatmosphäre würde bewirken, dass der Satellit nach ein, zwei Wochen bereits abtauchen würde.
Weil da einfach noch so viel Restatmo ist, die bremst.
Und was man jetzt macht, man misst mit dem Beschleunigungsmessen die Bremskräfte, die auf die Satellitenhülle wirken. Und die werden dann gegengesteuert mit Ionen-Triebwerken. Man sagt, das ist ein Drag-Free-Satellit. Das heißt, dass der Satellit ungestört fliegt von diesen Störkräften. Wirklich im frei-gravitativen Fall. Und damit lässt sich diese niedrige Höhe auch über mehrere Jahre aufrechterhalten.
Das heißt, diese Triebwerke gleichen quasi den Atmosphären-Gegendruck in dem Moment sofort aus, vollständig?
Das wäre so, als würden wir mit dem Fahrrad den Gegenwind spüren und erfassen. Und dann mit einem kleinen Antrieb das sofort kompensieren würden.
Also man schaut quasi die ganze Zeit auf den Tachometer und sieht so, oh jetzt würde ich langsamer werden, also muss ich hier mehr treten. Und die Verzögerung, also wie viel Latenz ist da?
Da ist überhaupt keine da. Das geht in Echtzeit, das sind ein paar Mikrosekunden vielleicht.
Das ist der Vorteil an diesen Ionentriebwerken, dass man die quasi so instantan anfahren kann.
Die Ionentriebwerke sind auch eine Besonderheit. Malerweise arbeiten Satellitenmotoren mit Impulsen. Und das hier ist aber proportional. Das heißt, es geht wirklich proportional auf den Satellitenwirken. Kraft wird dagegen gesteuert.
Ist das eigentlich auch ein Zukunftsmodell für Satelliten? Auch in der ISS ist ja eigentlich eine ideale Schwerelosigkeit und damit eine gleichmäßige Beschleunigung sehr wünschenswert, auch für die ganzen Experimente.
Ja, die ISS ist so riesig, dass man wirklich eben wie gesagt nur Schwerelosigkeit in einem Punkt hat. Und wenn man dann x Meter davon entfernt ist, dann lässt sie einfach nicht verhindern, dass man Gravitationseffekte hat. Also für ISS ist weniger vielleicht interessant, aber es sind in der Gravitationphysik einige Satellitenexperimente in Vorbereitung für derartige Missionen. Ist solche Technologie wichtig? Also da gibt es die Mission LISA, die Gravitationswellen nachweisen soll oder einen Missionsvorschlag G&G, der das Äquivalenzprinzip überprüfen soll auf 17 Stellen. Genau für derartige Missionen ist diese Technologie wichtig und schon ein Vorläufer.
Das heißt, GOCE besteht im Wesentlichen aus diesen sechs Quadern, diesen sechs Instrumenten. Gibt es sonst noch irgendetwas, was außerdem noch gemessen wird?
Nein.
Gar nichts.
Also es ist wirklich, man kann sagen, ein auf dieses Gravitations-Gradio-Meter zugeschnittenes Weltraumlabor.
Das ist einfach purer. Weil alles andere würde ja dann auch wieder stören.
Wir haben früher auch schon mal dieses Aristoteles, dieser Vorschlag, da war noch die Idee, das zu kombinieren mit einem Magnetfeldmessinstrument. Aber das erwies sich als äußerst kompliziert, weil auf beiden Seiten dann Kompromisse gemacht werden müssten, die einfach kontraproduktiv sind.
Goce ist ja gestartet dann 2009, da gab es ja auch noch mal ein paar Schwierigkeiten. Eigentlich sollte das Ding ja schon 2008 abheben. Was ist da passiert?
Ja, es waren Probleme mit der Fertigstellung dieser Beschleunigungsmesse. Aber dann irgendwann, mit etlichen Jahren Verzögerung, wurde die Mission 2009 gestartet. Am ersten Tag, an dem auch die ganzen Planungen waren für das Start-Event, musste noch mal der Start verschoben werden. Der Start erfolgte im Plesetsk in Russland, also ungefähr 1000 Kilometer nördlich von Moskau. Normalerweise äußerst zuverlässige Rakete wird dafür verwendet. Aber der Start musste verschoben werden, ganz einfach, weil das Türrelais für die Öffnung des Silos für diesen Satelliten am ersten Tag sich nicht öffnete. Und man musste das Relais auswechseln, und am zweiten Tag klappte dann alles wunderbar. Es gibt sehr menschliche Sachen.
Und man hatte da auch ein relativ breites Startfenster. Das war jetzt kein Problem?
Nein, es war kein Problem, außer dass unsere Nerven beinahe am Ende waren.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Warum ist das Ding in Plesses gestartet worden?
Das weiß ich eigentlich selbst nicht. Dieser Typ Rakete wird in Plesses gestartet.
Das ist eine Rock-Hot-Rakete.
Und das ist einfach auch kostengünstiger als z.B. amerikanische Trägeraketen oder europäische.
Für kleine Systeme. März 2009 ging es dann los. Das heißt, jetzt haben wir Juni 2012, jetzt ist das Ding schon gut drei Jahre und ein paar zerquetschte unterwegs. Der Start war dann erfolgreich und unproblematisch.
Die ersten Monate werden dann verwendet, um jedes der Instrumente und Sensoren zu testen und einzuschalten und auf Funktionsweise zu prüfen. Ab November 2009 lieferte der Satellit reguläre Daten. Wunderschön. Und wir waren begeistert. Das lief zwei Monate ohne jedes Problem und die ganzen Vorbereitungen.
Warum liefertet er erst seit November Daten, wenn er schon im März gestartet ist?
Das ist einfach, man sagt, a commissioning phase. Das heißt, Stück für Stück müssen die Instrumente eingeschaltet und getestet und geeicht werden. Das dauert mehrere Monate.
Also man hat sozusagen alle sechs, einen nach dem anderen, erstmal in Betrieb genommen?
Nicht nur das, sondern auch die Sternensensoren. Man muss schauen, dass die Orientierung richtig ist, dass die GPS-Empfänger funktionieren, dass der Daten-Downlink sauber funktioniert. All diese Dinge werden erprobt.
Okay, da muss man sich auch wirklich sehr sicher sein, dass man diesen Daten auch glauben schenken mag, dass man ein neues Telefon einschaltet und los geht's.
Das muss man sich auch klarmachen. Jeder Forschungssatellit ist ein Prototyp. D.h., man arbeitet immer mit Prototypen. Der erste Schuss muss sofort funktionieren.
Das ist eine enorme Herausforderung. Was führte dann so der Begeisterung, wenn man sich die Daten angeschaut hat?
Am Jahresende hatten wir bereits erstens, der Satellit umfliegt die Erde in ungefähr 90 Minuten. Mit jedem neuen Umlauf bekommt man Daten dazu.
Das ist eine Flugbahn um die Pole herum?
Fast um die Pole herum. Bei 90 Grad wäre es eine Polbahn. sie ist leicht gekippt. Der Grund dafür ist, dass die Satellitenbahn immer der Sonne zugewandt sein muss. Also man sagt, Sonnen synchron, damit die Sonnenpaneele auch ständig beschienen werden und Energie liefern.
Weil das ja auch permanent messen muss und permanent Daten braucht.
Das hat den Nachteil, dass die zwei Polekappen dann ohne Daten sind.
Leider.
Mit einem Öffnungswinkel von 6 Grad. Aber das wussten wir und das muss man einfach in Kauf nehmen. Die Bahn ist so definiert, dass nach 61 Tagen ein sehr dichtes Netz von Messungen über die ganze Erde entsteht, das komplett ist. Wir sagen, das ist ein Zyklus. Und dann beginnt wieder ein neuer Zyklus.
Und im November war der erste Zyklus schon durch?
Zu Jahreswende 2010 war der erste Zyklus zu Ende, November und Dezember. Und wir konnten schon ein erstes Gravitationsmodell errechnen. Und das sah alles prima aus.
So wie erwartet?
Man muss sagen, ich mag nicht gern Sensationen. Einfach so wie erwartet. Tolle Qualität. Wir waren begeistert. Es ist ja wirklich ein komplexes System, dass das alles funktioniert. Wir haben ein paar Besonderheiten gesehen. Da waren nur irgendwelche Einflüsse da von Sonnen, Winden, die wir am Anfang noch nicht erklären konnten und die wir korrigieren mussten. Aber im Prinzip war alles so nach Erwartung.
Und jetzt sind viele weitere Durchläufe, viele weitere 61 Tageblöcke hinterhergekommen?
Da kamen leider dann zwei Schreckperioden. Die erste war im Februar 2010, wo ein Boardcomputer praktisch ausfiel. Man hat dann allerdings einen Backup-Computer. Aber das dauert einige Wochen, man muss alles neu kalibrieren. Das war wirklich ein Schreckmoment. Man musste dann vom Computer A auf Computer B umschalten. Das haben wir dann ohne Herzinfarkt überstanden. Und die Prozessierung ging dann im März 2010 weiter. Und im Sommer des gleichen Jahres waren dann Probleme mit dem Backup-Computer. Das war dann wirklich eine heikle Phase. Und es dauerte zwei Monate, dass der Satellit nur noch minimal erreichbar war. Sozusagen ein Notsignal. Die ESA-Leute von Esteg haben unglaublich hart daran gearbeitet, zusammen mit der Industrie alle Möglichkeiten auszuladen, was hier los sein könnte. Und man hat dann nach vielen Überlegungen versucht, die Temperatur des B-Prozessors rauf zu erhöhen. Und dann plötzlich gab der Satellit wieder die Antwort und lieferte wieder Daten.
Das heißt, ihm war zu kalt?
Ihm war zu kalt, ja. Das war ganz eine heikle Sache. Man hat dann im Labor versucht zu verstehen, was da genau los war. Auf jeden Fall seitdem läuft das im Wesentlichen unterbrechungsfrei. Aber das war ein ganz heikler Moment. Und man muss wirklich sagen, die Boardcomputers sind eigentlich das am wenigsten kritischste Element eines derartigen Sensorsystems. Das heißt, alle Leute von ESA und wir auch waren unglaublich überrascht, dass ausgerechnet an dieser Stelle die Probleme auftraten.
Und dann auch noch gleich mit zweien. Heißt das, dass der erste dann auch schon unter diesem Temperaturproblem gelitten hat?
Weiß man nicht. Meines Wissens ist das einfach ungeklärt. Ich glaube, jetzt könnte man mit dem heutigen Wissen, wenn B ausfallen würde, wieder auf A zurückgehen.
Aber das macht man natürlich jetzt nicht ohne Not. Aber einen dritten gibt es nicht. Es gab nur die zwei.
Es gab nur die zwei und es war auf Messerschneide.
Das ist mal diskutiert worden, gleich mit dreien hochzugehen. Ich meine, es gibt ja auch das dreifache Ausfallsicherheit vorgesehen.
Ja, aber es ist natürlich alles sehr aufwendig. Und normalerweise ist das ein Element, an dem nie etwas schiefgeht.
Das sind immer die Stellen, wo es dann tatsächlich passiert. Erstaunlich, auch erstaunlich, dass man dann auch noch die Möglichkeit hat, so aus der Ferne etwas wieder auf die Sprühe zu helfen.
Ich finde es faszinierend. Es ist wirklich toll. Es passiert auch immer an Wochenenden.
Welcher Teil der ESA hat sich damit beschäftigt?
Das sind die Leute in Nordwijk und in Darmstadt.
Also beim STIG und beim ESOK.
Aber der Missionsleiter, Herr Floberghagen, der sitzt bei Israel in Fraskati. Der war natürlich auch ständig da eingeschaltet. Aber es geht ja darum, dass man praktisch im Labor Dinge nachspielt. Dass man spielen kann, die oben am Satelliten passieren. Man muss alle möglichen Dinge simulieren.
Da ist die Kooperation gerade zwischen dem STIG, wo die ganzen Tests gemacht werden, und die Basisdaten gesammelt werden, wie sich das Ding generell verhält, zusammen mit der Erfahrung aus der Flugsteuerung vom ESOK, zusammenfließend für die Analysen.
Und zusammen mit den Industriefirmen, die zum Beispiel diese Prozessoren geliefert haben.
Das heißt, jetzt läuft alles prima, und alle zwei Monate hat man quasi noch mal eine weitere Messung des selben Datensatzes. Diese Wiederholung, was verbessert das? Verbessert das die Genauigkeit? Oder gibt es auch eine Änderung über die Zeit?
Das klingt langweilig, aber im Prinzip geht es nur um Genauigkeit. Das heißt, mit jedem Zyklus erhöht sich die Genauigkeit. Zeitvariationen wäre eine sehr interessante Sache. Da liegen wir eigentlich an der Grenze. Das heißt, Effekt von großen Erdbeben ist vielleicht gerade noch sichtbar. Aber die Mission wurde so ausgelegt, dass man vor allem räumliche Details erkennen kann und das geht auf Kosten der Sensitivität gegenüber Zeitvariationen. Diese amerikanisch-deutsche Mission GRACE, die ist ausgelegt auf Zeitvariationen, liefert aber keine Details. Das sind zwei komplementäre Ansätze. Hier geht es um statische Gravitationsfeld und mit jedem Zyklus gewinnen wir an Genauigkeit und Empfindlichkeit.
Aber was könnte diese Messung stören? Inwiefern führt ein Erdbeben zu einer Veränderung?
Man hat schlagartig eine vollkommen andere Anordnung der Massen um den Erdbeben her.
Also durch die Verschiebung selbst, dass es danach anders bleibt?
An das Japaner Erdbeben, an das fürchterliche, hat sie praktisch eine Plattengrenze enorm verschoben, schlagartig nach oben.
Wie fein löst den GOCE auf?
100 Kilometer klingt nicht viel, ist aber fürs Gravitationsfeld sehr, sehr viel.
Also 100 Quadrat?
Sie können ungefähr sagen, Veränderungen von einem Quadrat mit 100 Kilometer Seitenlänge zu einem Nachbarquadrat, das ist sichtbar.
Und wenn jetzt so ein Tsunami da durch die Ozeane pflügt, das führt ja dann auch zu Verschiebungen, könnte das sein?
Nee, muss man ehrlich sagen, nicht messbar.
So temporär der Vorgang?
Also es ist eigentlich alles fokussiert auf dieses sehr genaue Geoid und die sehr kleinen räumlichen Variationen in der Irranziehung.
Das heißt, mit den Daten, die jetzt schon da sind, hat man auf jeden Fall nochmal ein genaueres Bild im Vergleich zu dem, was man vorher eigentlich so noch gar nicht hatte, diesen Blick. Also es gibt jetzt das erste Mal überhaupt so ein Modell in dieser Vollständigkeit. Und gibt es da Überraschungen?
Also Überraschungen vielleicht nicht. Was wir das erste Mal jetzt erreichen ist, übrigens zusammen mit einer zweiten Methode, nämlich mit der Radar-Altimetrie, die die Ozeanoberfläche misst, haben wir das erste Mal global konsistent diese Ozean-Topographie, d.h. diese Berge und Täler der Ozeane. Wir können also jetzt ohne ozeanografische Messungen nachweisen, wie die Ozeane fließen, und zwar global konsistent. Und das ist, glaube ich, eine Riesenerrungenschaft.
Aber wie misst man nur aus der Höhe und der Masse die Strömung?
Man kombiniert zwei Verfahren. Einerseits GOCE liefert diese Geoid-Fläche, diese Ruhe-Fläche.
D.h. man weiß, wo der Mittelpunkt sein müsste, wo sozusagen das normale Null liegt.
Genau. Die Erhebung misst man dann mit einem anderen Verfahren, mit Radar-Altimetrie. mit Satelliten misst man die Entfernung zur Meeressoberfläche.
Aber die ist ja dann wiederum sehr abhängig vom Wellengang oder wird da aber auch so oft gemessen?
Das mittelt sich raus, weil der Kegel, der Radar-Kegel relativ breit ist. Also Wellen spielen keine Rolle, aber man muss doch über die Zeit mitteln. Diese Missionen Radar-Altimetrie, die gibt es schon seit fast 20 Jahren. Man nimmt das Mittel über diese 20 Jahre, sodass man wirklich eine sehr zuverlässige Meeresoberfläche, wirkliche Meeresoberfläche hat. Und aus dem Unterschied dieser zwei bekommt man diese Ozeanberge und Täler, die eben nur maximal ein bis zwei Meter sind. Die Struktur dieser Berge, also die höheren Linien und ihr Abstand sind direkt proportional zur Ozeangeschwindigkeit. Das heißt, es lässt sich nicht nur das Bild der Ozeanströmungen ableiten, sondern auch deren Geschwindigkeit. Sodass man genau sieht, dass an der Westflanke des Golfstroms das Wasser relativ schnell sich Richtung Norden, Richtung Europa bewegt, während die Ostflanke Richtung Spanien hin sehr, sehr flach ist und dort das Wasser sehr langsam zurückströmt. Und das hat man jetzt global. Zum Beispiel arbeiten wir in München zusammen mit dem Alfred-Wegner-Institut in Bremerhaven und dem Deutschen Geodätischen Forschungsinstitut an Zirkumpolarstrom. Das ist ein sehr dynamisches Ozeangebiet, eines der wichtigsten Ozeangebiete, um dort erstmals sehr, sehr genau die Ocean-Topografie und die Geschwindigkeiten abzuleiten. Das ist wieder implizit für die Klimaforschung interessant. Wie viel Wärme, wie viel Material wird transportiert, in welchen Zeiten verändern sich diese Strömungssysteme mit der Zeit. Das alles ist nachweisbar.
Jetzt hat man sozusagen das Referenzmodell.
Und das wird auch noch für die nächsten 20 bis 50 Jahre verwendbar sein, seit man hat diese Referenz.
Gut, schon läuft er noch. Wie lange hält er noch durch?
Er sollte eigentlich schon fertig sein, wurde verlängert und wird voraussichtlich bis Mitte oder Ende nächsten Jahres laufen. Momentan sind wir in Diskussion mit den Leuten von ESA, ob man nicht die Bahn noch weiter absenkt ab Sommer dieses Jahres. Dann hat man noch größere Entfernung und eventuell wird man das machen. Also noch mal um 10 bis 15 Kilometer die Bahn absenken.
Das bringt schon wieder was für die Genauigkeit?
Das bringt schon wieder was für die Genauigkeit, ja. Und in der Schlussphase der Mission kann man sich das erlauben. Das heißt, selbst wenn das nicht ganz gelingen würde, wäre irgendwie nicht der Erfolg der Mission gefährdet.
Würde ich jetzt mal fragen, warum nur 15 Kilometer, wenn man auch noch tiefer fliegen könnte? Ich meine, runter kommt es dann irgendwann?
Ja, da fliegt man schon fast über dem Hausgiebel.
Die Frage ist ja eigentlich eher, was kann dieser Ionenantrieb an Atmosphärenwiderstand ausgleichen?
Genau.
Das wäre dann schon das Maximum?
Das sind sehr kleine Kräfte, die da aufgewendet werden.
Das heißt, jetzt fliegt man einfach nicht direkt am Limit, sondern so gerade drüber.
Oder schön im Marsch.
Und dann würde man ans Limit gehen und wenn er dann knallt, dann okay, schade.
Ja, man macht das natürlich sehr vorsichtig. Es muss ja auch die Sicherheit gewährt sein. GOCE wird ja nicht als Weltraumschrott in der Umlaufplan bleiben, sondern wird dann in den Ozean fallen. Allerdings gesteuert. Und das muss natürlich alles sehr sicher und sauber abgearbeitet werden.
Und das als Materialien, die nicht so gut verglühen?
Teilweise verglühen es und teilweise eben nicht.
Da bleibt was übrig. Aber plumpst dann definiert. Und das ist schon von vornherein mit einberechnet worden, dass man quasi mit der Restenergie dann eben auch den richtigen Punkt findet. Was für Anwendungen außer dem, was wir jetzt besprochen haben, lassen sich denn sonst noch so aus diesen Daten herausziehen? Also der Einfluss auf die Strömung ist offensichtlich. Aber ist es jetzt nur das Wasser, was interessant ist?
Gewinnt man da auch für geologische Erkundungen? Auch die feste Erde. Ich habe ja gesagt, jeder dichte Unterschied spielt eine Rolle. Das heißt, man schaut eigentlich in gewisser Weise mit dem Instrument ins Erdinner. Das wäre schön, wenn das genauso wäre, wie ich es gerade gesagt habe. Der Blick ins Erdinner ist nicht eindeutig. Die Idee ist, dass man zusammen mit anderen geophysikalischen Methoden, insbesondere mit der seismischen Tomographie, in Kombination den Blick ins Erdinner verfeinert. Was GOCE sehr sauber zeigt, ist z.B. erstmals das Gravitationsfeld unter der Eiskappe von der Antarktis. Wir sehen sehr sauber die tektronischen Strukturen unter dem Eisschild. Die Geophysiker können jetzt erforschen, ob dort aktiver Vulkanismus stattfindet, ob es früher in der eisfreien Zeit Meteorolyteneinschläge gegeben hat. Diese Dinge können jetzt untersucht werden.
Das heißt, das lässt sich aus den angegebenen Fällen herausrechnen. Das drängt sich nicht auf, sondern bedarf noch mal weiterer Forschung. Aber so Krater etc. könnte man entsprechend nachweisen. Beziehungsweise anhand bestehender Krater diese Modelle entsprechend überprüfen.
Für Geophysiker ist auch sehr interessant Afrika, weil dieser Kontinent insgesamt relativ hoch ist, also nicht in einem Massengleichgewicht sich befindet. Auch für Afrika ist jetzt das Gravitationsfeld der Erde sehr viel detaillierter und zuverlässiger bekannt. Anderes Gebiet ist Himalaya und Tibet, wo wir jetzt sehr sauberes Gravitationsfeld haben. Das heißt, wir sind uns sehr zuversichtlich, dass schöne Geophysik machbar ist. Ich war letztes Jahr auf einer Tagung in London zur dynamischen Topographie der festen Erde. Und da wurden diese Dinge bereits diskutiert.
Das heißt, es fängt eigentlich erst an, dass man jetzt auf neue Ideen kommt, was man aus den Daten noch machen kann?
Geophysik läuft es jetzt erst an. Das ist eigentlich auch vernünftig. Die warten das Missionsende ab, weil wir dann die höchste Genauigkeit haben. Erst dann ist es eigentlich voll lohnenswert, sich die Details anzuschauen. Allerdings läuft schon in Deutschland ein Schwerpunktprogramm der Deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft, in dem unter anderem auch die geophysikalischen Anwendungen bereits in Projekten untersucht werden. Ein weiteres Gebiet sind die Höhensysteme. Es ist mit GOCE jetzt erstmals möglich, die Höhensysteme der verschiedenen Kontinente auf ein Niveau zu bringen. Da gibt es eine ganz simple Anwendung, das ist Niveau en Monde mit GPS, sagen wir. Die klassische Methode der Höhenbestimmung ist es Niveau en Monde. Das sind die Vermessungsingenieure, die durch diese Lupe schauen, durch diese Wasserwaage schauen, um Höhenunterschiede zu bestimmen. Das ist aber ein sehr aufwendiges Verfahren. Wesentlich einfacher wäre es, GPS-Empfänger würde die gleichen Höhen liefern. Das tut er aber nicht, weil GPS eigentlich nur geometrische Informationen gibt und nicht Höhen über NN.
Also es gibt schon Höhen, aber sie sind nicht besonders genau?
Nein, die sind vor allem nicht physikalisch relevant. Die sagen einem nicht, ob man oben oder unten ist. In Kombination mit GOCE bekommt man jetzt diese Meereshöhen auf ein, zwei Zentimeter genau in Europa oder in USA oder in Kanada. Und das ist sehr, sehr bequem für alle möglichen Ingenieuranwendungen. Es kann auch nicht mehr passieren, dass, wenn man den Kanaltunnel baut zwischen Großbritannien und Frankreich, dass man einfach da vor der Frage steht, wie groß ist der Höhenunterschied, bevor man Sporen beginnt. Man hatte in England ein eigenes Höhensystem und in Frankreich. Und es war relativ schwierig nachzuweisen, wie groß der Höhenunterschied war, nachdem man ja keine Verbindung hatte.
Und jetzt haben wir quasi eine Referenz und könnte...
Ja, sehr, sehr genau das verbinden.
Wobei, die haben es auch trotzdem geschafft, den Turm zu bauen.
Die haben es trotzdem geschafft. Glück gehabt. Nein, nein, aber es war sehr aufwendig.
Ach so, das wäre jetzt einfacher?
Ja, wesentlich einfacher. Einfach so auch in Zukunft, dass man das als ein Stück Software in jeden GPS-Empfänger einbauen könnte. Das heißt, sie schauen sich direkt die Meereshöhe auf ihren GPS-Empfänger an. Und das finde ich eine sehr schöne Sache.
Einfach als feste Daten oder jetzt noch mal relativ zu dem, was man ist?
Ich habe gesagt, GOCE liefert ein Endprodukt irgendwann. Das kann man als digitalen Bestand einbauen in jeden GPS-Empfänger.
Heißt das jetzt sozusagen auch die gängigen Angaben irgendwelcher Dörfer, die am Eingang schreiben, sind so und so viel Meter über normal 0, dass diese Zahlen gegebenenfalls angepasst werden müssen?
Ob man es tut, weiß ich nicht, aber das müsste sicher angepasst werden.
Und wie groß können die zu erwartenden Verschiebungen sein?
In Europa sind es vielleicht Zentimeterbeträge, aber ich glaube, in Himalaya oder Afrika oder sowas, da können es Meterbeträge sein.
Warum ist es da mehr?
Weil es einfach höher ist. Weil man in Europa mit sehr viel Aufwand eben schon seit Jahrhunderten Niveau le Mans macht, während man in Afrika andere Sorgen hat.
Das heißt, Goja hat weitreichend langfristigen Einfluss auf so ziemlich alles, was sich mit Landvermessung und weiteren Sinne und damit dann eben auch Klimamodelle und andere Umwelt-Erdbeobachtungssysteme betrifft.
So ist es ja. Und ich würde auch erwarten, dass ähnliche Missionen vielleicht in absehbarer Zukunft für Planeten eingesetzt werden, weil das ein sehr kompaktes Verfahren ist. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das sehr geeignet wäre für Mars oder Venus.
Um einfach nochmal diese Planeten dann entsprechend genauso das schwere Feld zu bestimmen. Aber das wird doch jetzt auch teilweise schon gemacht.
Es wird aus Bahnen gemacht. Da hat man wieder das gleiche Dilemma, dass man relativ weit weg ist und eben nur den freien Fall misst. Und mit Gradiometrie kämen wir da sehr viel weiter.
Aber das müssten dann auch wieder dedizierte Missionen sein, die eben auch nichts anderes tun als das. Was ist mit dem Mond?
Ja, der Mond läuft gerade. Eine amerikanische Schwerefeldmission.
Welche ist das?
Jetzt stehe ich gerade auf dem...
Die heißen auch alle immer so ähnlich. Maluna... Ach so, Grail ist das natürlich klar. Das hatten wir ja sogar hier in der letzten Ausgabe. Genau, Gravity Recovery and Interior Laboratory. Das hatten wir in der letzten Ausgabe erwähnt.
Das ist das Prinzip wieder von zwei Satelliten, also zwei Testmassen, die frei um den Mond fallen.
Ja, und inwiefern würde jetzt die GOCE-Methode gegenüber der GRADE-Methode noch einen Unterschied bringen?
Ich hätte für die Mondmission eine Gradiometermission bevorzugt. Ganz einfach, weil man nur einen Satelliten hat. Da sind zwei Satelliten in den Mond umlaufbar. Das ist eine heikle Sache. Und weil man ja am Mond nicht zugreifen kann auf das GPS-System, hat man eine vollkommen andere Situation als auf der Erde mit der GRADE-Mission. Man könnte sagen, dass ein Gradiometer ein relativ autarkes Instrument ist. Das, unabhängig vom Außenkontakt, sein Gravitationsfeld des jeweiligen Planeten messen kann.
Wie tief ist denn dieser Blick in die Erde? Sie haben ja gesagt, man kann die Tektonik sehen, man sieht vielleicht Krater, also ich leite mal davon ab, man kann dann quasi auch mal die Platten auch als solche irgendwie nachweisen, von denen man im Wesentlichen schon weiß, aber man sieht es dann quasi auch wirklich in den Zahlen. Wie tief geht dieser Blick oder was ist zu erwarten, was man aus diesen Daten, wie tief man so in die Erde hineinblicken kann, wo bisher noch gar kein Zahlenmaterial vorhanden war?
Er geht eigentlich sehr tief in den Erdmantel hinein. Also nicht in den Erdkern, das wäre auch ein Thema, in den Erdmantel. Das heißt, wenn Sie Skewit betrachten, diese Kartoffel, dann ist eine der markantesten Formen ein Minimum südlich von Indien. Und jetzt wäre die erste Reaktion, was ist südlich von Indien? Das Maximum daneben ist bei Indonesien-Gunea. Das ist nicht korreliert mit den Kontinenten eigenartigerweise, weil das Gravitationsfeld der Kontinente praktisch relativ klein ist in seiner Wirkung. Dadurch, dass die Kontinente in einem Massengleichgewicht im Erdmantel schwimmen. Was man hier sieht in der Globalform des Geoids, sind Temperaturunterschiede im Wesentlichen im Erdmantel. Das heißt, es bildet sich die Wärme-Konvektionsströme des Erdmantels ab. Das ist das, was man sieht.
Das heißt, das ganze vor sich hin brodelnde Magma schlägt unterschiedlich heiß durch?
Ja, noch schöner wäre es, wenn man reinfokussieren könnte auf die Grenze zwischen Kern und Mantel. Also einen flüssigen Außenkern und Erdmantel. Das wäre eine sehr interessante Grenzfläche, aber das ist so nicht möglich.
Um es nochmal klar zu machen, also Mantel ist so der Bereich, bis knapp 3000 Kilometer in die Erde rein. Und dann ist es nochmal etwa die gleiche Strecke, wirklich bis zur Mitte, ein bisschen mehr.
Und der äußere Ehrkern ist sehr heiß und flüssig. Und die Wechselwirkung zwischen diesem äußeren Kern und Mantel, der ist natürlich sehr interessant.
Das heißt, da könnte es auch noch durchaus sein, dass grundsätzlich neue Erkenntnisse gewonnen werden?
Ja, ganz sicher. Nicht notwendigerweise von GOCE.
Aber von künftigen Messungen oder Auswertungen. Haben wir denn noch einen wichtigen Aspekt unberührt gelassen, hier bei unserer Reise um den Erdmantel?
Ich glaube, dass wir alle wesentlichen Punkte angesprochen haben. Sogar die Zukunft.
Sogar die Zukunft. Ja, die lassen wir ja hier nicht außen vor. Gibt es denn weitere Planungen in ähnlicher Form? Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, für die Erde war es das erst mal. Man könnte ja nicht unbedingt erwarten, dass man es noch feiner hinbekommt.
Die jungen Kollegen arbeiten gerade an Konzepten für Folgemissionen. Da wäre dann der Fokus nicht mehr auf dem statischen Gravitationsfeld, sondern an den Zeitvariationen.
Okay, also über die Zeit.
Diese Zeitvariationen sind im Wesentlichen verursacht nicht durch Prozesse der festen Erde, sondern mehr Atmosphäre, Ozeane, Eis. Das ist ein Stichwort. Abschmelzende Eiskappen sind ein Masseneffekt. Mehrere Spiegelveränderungen, Veränderungen der kontinentalen Hydrologie.
Müssen man dazu noch feiner messen, als man es bisher getan hat, oder nur anders?
Man will noch feiner messen. Grace macht ja dieartige Sachen schon. Und das will man noch genauer machen. Und da wird schon sehr intensiv dran gearbeitet.
Also für planetare Missionen ist bisher noch nichts im Regal.
Nicht, dass ich weiß.
Könnte aber passieren.
Wird sicher passieren.
Wird sicher passieren. Gut, dann lassen wir das mal als Voraussage im Raum stehen. Herr Rummel, vielen Dank.
Sehr gerne.
Für die Ausführungen hier zu GOCE und der ganzen Frage der Erdschwere. Ich fühle mich jetzt auch ganz schwer. Und bringen wir das Ganze zu Ende. Ich sage Tschüss und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Hier bei Raumzeit geht bald wieder weiter.